conférence de presse cet après midi de
jean luc mélenchon pour tenter
d'éteindre la polémique avec le leader
de la france insoumise a lui même
déclenché hier plus de précisions tout
de suite avec mona hamou dès lors en
direct du siège du parti dans le xème
ans on à jean luc mélenchon et est au
coeur d'une polémique depuis hier est
exactement de grégory à sète une
polémique qu'il aurait préféré éviter
quelques mots avant la campagne
présidentielle tout a commencé sur un
plateau télé alors que jean luc
mélenchon évoqué la campagne
présidentielle et certains faits divers
notamment les attentats de toulouse de
montauban en 2012 perpétrés par mois med
meira il a affirmé je cite tout est
écrit ed avance vous verrez que la
dernière semaine de la campagne
présidentielle nous aurons un grave
incident ou meurtre des propos qui ont
tout de suite mis le feu aux poudres
jean luc mélenchon a été accusé de
complot tison je vous propose
je vous propose de revenir sur ses
déclarations écoute et vous verrez que
dans la dernière semaine de la campagne
présidentielle nous aurons un grave
incident ou un meurtre
cela est hemera en 2012 cela a été
l'attentât la dernière semaine sur les
champs elysées avant on avait eu papy
voise dont plus personne n'a jamais
entendu parler après tout ça c'est écrit
d'avancé
nous aurons le petit personnage sorti du
chapeau nous aurons les événements
gravissimes qui va une fois de plus
permettre de montrer du doigt les
musulmans et d'inventer une guerre
civile
voilà ses bateaux tout ça - ah quelle
réaction après ces propos
eh bien ces propos ont été jugés comme
étant complotistes ont suscité de vives
réactions à droite comme à gauche mais
pas seulement
les familles des victimes ont été
consternés par ces déclarations
notamment notamment le père d'abel
chennouf albert chennouf meilleur le
père du caporal abel chez nous et l
actif à yb nous y atteignent la mère du
militaire imad il vit athènes tous les
deux et qui ont été assassinés et par
mohamed merah en 2012 je vous propose
d'écouter leurs réactions
les propos de jean luc mélenchon sont
inadmissibles et ne devrait même pas
être tenus je suis la mère de imad
militaire mort debout face à
l'obscurantisme en mars 2012
le respect c'est un minimum pour
l'honneur de mon fils d autres victimes
et des familles endeuillées et dans tout
ça quelle est la position de la france
insoumise depuis le début de cette
polémique
eh bien depuis le début depuis ces
déclarations les proches de jean luc
mélenchon mélenchon parle on tente de
contenir l incendie de prendre la
décision du leader de la france ont
soumis des de clarifier ses propos sur
les plateaux télé c'est ce qu'a fait
clémentine autain chez nos confrères de
ces nous écoutez la
ce qu'il a voulu dire c'est que les
assassins qui font ça savent à quel
moment ils le font ce qu'il visait c'est
l'extrême droite qui instrumentalisent
ce qui arrive pour affirmer des propos
xénophobes liberticide antirépublicain
quant à jean luc mélenchon et bien il a
dénoncé un bad buzz
affligeant aujourd'hui en conférence de
presse il a réitéré son soutien aux
familles des victimes et puis il a
condamné fermement elle les menaces dont
il fait l'objet et notamment cette vidéo
d'un youtuber d'extrême droite qui met
en scène une attaque armée contre un
électeur de jean luc mélenchon jean luc
mélenchon qui a porté plainte et qui a
qualifié cette vidéo comme étant en
appel au meurtre
reste à savoir si cette polémique est
bien va entacher la candidature du
leader de la france en 6 jean luc
mélenchon
merci mon âme ou dès lors en direct du
siège de la france en soumises dans le
10e arrondissement de paris